the corona virus is now blamed for
killing more than one hundred and
forty-six thousand people worldwide some
countries in Europe are lifting
restrictions on movement but British
leaders are still worried the outbreak
has not peaked there as MTS tie-up
Reports Prince William is talking about
his family and the acting Prime Minister
has extended Britain's locked down for
another three weeks the worst thing that
we could do right now is to ease up too
soon
standing in for a still recovering Boris
Johnson Britain's Secretary of State
says keeping the country closed is
necessary to protect a health care
system still convulsing under the strain
of so many coronavirus cases the UK's
death toll is expected to surpass 14,000
today a figure weighing heavily on the
minds of everyone especially healthcare
workers I think if you if you try and
think about the whole situation it's too
much Prince William and wife Kate say
the coronavirus crisis hit home after
Prince Charles's diagnosis I have to
admit at first I was quite concerned he
fits the profile of somebody at the AG's
act which is you know very risky and so
it was a little bit worried
the royal couple say people also need to
make mental health a priority given so
many are concerned about so much I think
very carefully about my grandparents you
are you know at the age they're at we're
doing everything we can to make sure
that they're you know isolated away and
protected from this but but it does
worry me there are some early glimmers
of hope elsewhere including in Spain
which is allowing some factory and
construction workers to go back to work
while in Italy which was so badly hit by
the coronavirus some regions are
allowing stores to reopen but in Wuhan
China where this all began an admission
from the Chinese government the death
toll there is over 50% what they
originally reported precede us this
morning in Pio style London